let's get the feminist so angry right
now oh sure let's do it let's go the the
ones the one story that I always bring
up that always triggers like this wave
like I'll see my name trending after I
after I talk about it I'm like okay you
know whatever I don't care
um as women start making more money
men who make as much money as them are
unattractive oh and so we have this we
have a study lack of economically
attractive men to blame for decline in
marriage rates study suggests this is a
big story in 2019. yeah and there was a
there was another story from the New
York Post talking about women in their
30s struggle to find men who make as
much money as them and the funny thing
about it
the story about uh women not being able
to find men to make as much money as
them it's like the initial assumption
was where are all the good men like why
is it so hard for a woman in her 30s who
makes 50 000 a year to find a man who's
equal to her and the issue is they seem
to think these men don't exist that's
not the case it's that if you're a 35
year old woman who makes 50 000 a year
and you're like you know a manager at a
business of some sort
a man who's 35 years old who's a manager
who makes 50k is not trying to date you
he's trying to date a 22 year old
I'm not saying that's a good thing I'm
not I'm not passing judgment or
criticizing women I'm saying quite
literally dudes want to date young women
and it's like we were mentioning just a
moment ago in the previous segment about
how you know uh these guys who have
careers and have cars and have
apartments are on dating apps or
Instagram and they can hit up this
college student or a chicken Idaho who's
like you know now she's she's accessed
she has access to every man so this this
35 year old guy is not trying to hook up
for the most part or at least I should
say is a tendency so then you end up
with women upset they can't find
economically attractive men and then you
end up with a study talking about
divorces that when uh men don't make
more money than the woman the women
don't like want to be in the women don't
want to be in the relationship anymore
yeah um and this is an uncomfortable
reality for women and the thing is is
that women got to understand that men
have standards too it's just that when
yeah I know it's shocking right upstairs
because like the thing is this if a
woman says I want a man that makes a
certain amount of money hundred thousand
dollars a year since it be what most
women want want six feet tall attractive
whatever confidence that's okay that's
considered preferences but if a man says
I want a woman that's young attractive
and not annoying or crass that's
considered discrimination and that's the
problem and a lot of women don't
understand this because if a man speaks
his mind of what he really likes in
women he can get canceled be called a
misogynist whatever it is so very few
men tell the truth about what they're
attracted to in women and the reality
ladies I'll tell you
the more the more money you make and the
older you get the less negotiating power
you have in the relationship world
because the things that make a woman
attractive are not the same things that
make a man attractive women think a lot
of the times tend to base their value on
masculine traits how much they earn
their career Etc that is asinine that's
like me saying Hey listen I look really
good in some heels I can walk in a dress
and as a matter of fact I'm really
feminine every girl would be repulsive I
told her she's like oh no that's that's
not what I'm into that's exactly how men
feel when a woman says I'm a career
woman I'm strong and independent it's
just that men rarely voice this because
to say that you're immediately going to
be hit with some kind of Shame language
so most guys don't voice what they
really want in women and they just act
on it instead what happens older women
get left on left uh left in the dust and
the men that they actually want to make
money have status Etc they go for
younger more attractive girls because
men are attracted to Youth and Beauty no
matter what Society wants to say reality
does not adhere to social constructs I
have to say this all the time to like
Angry feminist reality does not adhere
to social constructs just because you
have a degree and you make money that's
cool nothing wrong with that but
understand it's not going to increase
your sexiness by having a career and
here's what we hear a lot of it you
always try to there's always some
defense like um imagine if a dude you
mentioned looking good in heels or
whatever I think imagine if a dude said
my goal is to be a stay-at-home dad and
raise kids you know I don't want to be
in the workplace I want to get married
and have kids at a young age
that's not attractive I mean there are
certainly women who find that attractive
of course there's no absolutes there's a
lot of different people with different
preferences but it's a tendency you say
something like that oh they get it this
is what triggers the feminists Tweet
about it because guys want to go off on
adventures guys want to go hunting guys
want to accomplish that goal they don't
want to be stuck at home they want to be
you know it's different obviously there
are guys that do they're guys I wish I
could spend more time with their kids
and there are people who are upset they
spend too much time in the office but
there are Tendencies so if you're if if
you're uh put it this way The House
Always Wins right you know why the house
always wins in a casino because the odds
for say roulette or for for for craps is
51 in The house's favor yep which means
over a long enough period of time you
will lose you can maybe go in throw that
dice at one time get lucky and win the
jackpot but that's the exception not the
rule when it comes to dating even if
it's just 51 percent of men who don't
like this and 51 of women who don't like
that that's a pressure where you and the
the dating Marketplace will keep
experiencing this and you'll say why is
it so hard for me to find a guy who just
wants to be a stay-at-home dad or a guy
who says why is it so hard to find a
woman who just wants to be the CEO of a
company to be my wife I got a perfect
segue for that you just said something
magical which I have to say on the
podcast as you guys know on our show we
bring ladies into the show a lot of
career women a lot of women that are
entrepreneurs and they ask us how do I
land a guy like this or they just you
know they toss me to the side whatever
the problem is that a lot of women don't
understand that concept you just said
a lot of women operate on possibilities
instead of probabilities and the reality
is the probability is when you have a
lot when you make money you're
successful you're a strong independent
woman and you're in your 30s the
probability that you're going to find a
attractive man that makes as much money
as you if not more is confident attract
all these traits that women typically
want and Men the probability is low but
the problem is this
I'm gonna say it a lot of women live in
a Disney fairy tale okay women are told
life is all good sugar and spice and on
top of that privileges are visible to
those that have it if a woman was
attractive in her 20s and late teens and
was getting attention from men she's
going to continue to think I will
continue to get the same attention and
validation from men into my 30s but they
don't realize until they're in their 30s
and they don't they're not necessarily
as attractive they can't compete right
on what men actually want Youth and
Beauty then that's when the reality hits
them and they operate on possibilities
well you know what it's still possible
for me to get my prince charming my uh
my prince but they don't realize that
that possibility is very slim and Men
fortunately for us we live in a
fact-based reality when it comes to
dating men know deep down you must
create if you don't create you're not
going to procreate period but women you
know they don't realize it until later
on that I work so hard for my career and
I can't get a guy but no you're using
masculine traits and now you've pretty
much pissed away your ability to have
that negotiating power to get a high
status guy have you ever seen the uh the
marketplace value study I think it was
okay cute but that this and I think they
deleted a lot of these because oh yeah
there was offensive to the woke but what
it shows is that
women start off young women have the
maximum possible societal value in terms
of what humans are willing to protect
and defend young young women start off
at 100 that's that's that's the line
young man guess where they start zero
below zero yeah well it's just the
bottom that's like on a scale of zero to
100 men are at zero when young men are
at zero why well they're younger so
they're not as attractive they're not
typically masculine and and you know
they're not ripped they're not chiseled
they haven't had any money they don't
need status they've earned nothing
they're starting from the bottom why
would anyone want that rarely with young
women however and this is mostly due to
to biology whether anyone wants to
believe it or not this is what the
studies show and I'm not saying it's a
good thing I'm just saying men are
attracted to young women for their
ability to to procreate they're
attractive they want to have kids they
want to have families what happens is
over time
Men start to become more valuable by
earning status making money collecting
resources and women start to become less
societally valuable again I'm not saying
it's a good thing
um because they're getting older and
their ability to to have kids is
dwindling and diminishing eventually
there's a Nexus point there's like a
point at which many I think it's around
30 yes they start to intersect they even
out and then what happens is women go
down and Men start going up so men who
are in I I think it might have been
cernovich was saying this could be wrong
like tomasi has a graph on it that shows
us access which is like the women's
Prime is like 18 to 24 right and then a
man is typically in their 30s you know
like 35 to 50 or something yeah 35 to
50. the thing is is that a woman's value
it shines the hardest and brightest but
it's for a smaller period of time for
men if they do the work of course you
know if you if you're 35 years old and
you're broke it don't matter but you
know if you if you do the work you're
you're you can uh Shine for a longer
period And I want to stress too this is
not a personal opinion of value this is
a number based on the study I'm
referring to looked at messages who was
getting hit up on dating on dating
websites yes and it wasn't so much as to
say like I think they outlined this
they're saying we're not saying people
are more or less valuable as human
beings we're saying that in the dating
World women get messages at a declining
rate from 24 and then onward men get an
increasing amount of message as as time
goes on but there was also another funny
metric in that where they found that
women tend to message men equal to their
age men always message 22 year olds yeah
it's it's uh and I know that study
you're talking about the university
between men between the ages of 18 all
the way to 60 almost always prefer women
between the ages of 18 to 24. you know
it's like it's 22 was like the number
yeah it was like the age of the man is
going up and the woman is just at 22 the
whole time yeah we had a 35 year old
woman on the show right late night show
and she was saying like yo I wish
someone told me these things when I was
younger because she would go now to the
club and it's like she's sitting at 22
years old getting picked up by guys you
know getting hollered out she's like wow
I'm not getting the same attention and
it's kind of like she understood if she
had choose that time back you know back
then which is like in her 20s properly
she could probably locked on a man that
she cared about her now it's kind of
like okay I messed up those years of my
life I'm 35 years old what do I have
left to give and your youth isn't there
and guys want you okay the problem is
that like girls don't really know what
men really want and Men I would say men
kind of know what women want but it's
kind of like they are putting themselves
in the Box saying hey you know what I
can have fun in my 20s get lit travel
men can afford to try to figure it out
women can't they can't that's the
difference like like well like like men
like you could take 10 to 15 years to
figure it out and come into your Prime
later on women don't get that benefit
you know like and the thing is is that
like I said they like to measure their
value in masculine standards which is
asinine because that's like me saying I
can fit just like I said earlier if I
could wear heels and walk in a dress you
should like me too and that's how women
sound when they have a career yeah they
based off masculine traits but you know
attractiveness matters but I think you
you know what you're saying about
masculine traits is is what I think
triggers feminists so severely yeah
definitely yeah the reason why like this
is the one video where it's like all of
a sudden I see all these feminists
tweeting about me is because they were
told their whole lives you need to get a
career you need to be the CEO you need
to break the glass ceiling and so
they're like okay that's what I got to
do then they hit their third they're in
their 30s and they are in that senior
level position or the VP position and
they're like I did it now how are my
prospects for the things I want and guys
are like oh I respect you but I don't
want to have a family with you exactly
and that must be like getting smacked in
the face with a bag of bricks see if you
could find men who do for sure but as
you already stated like what ends up
happening is women then have to start
lowering their standards to find a man
who's going to be and they will not do
it we won't do it from the show women
will never submit they'd rather die
alone with dogs and cats than submit to
a guy that they don't want and here's
the scary part they've been lied to like
you said their whole life so now's that
okay they're awakened to what's the
truth and it's like I don't I'm finding
because I don't I don't want to submit
well here's the problem though you have
to because that's your only way out now
because you waited too long to close
that Gap so I'm just saying to women out
there like if you hear this right now
you're young take it for what it is
because if you don't you wait too long
to find this man to settle down with
your 30s is kind of like okay what's
going to choose you over the 22 two girl
why and I'll say this too for the women
out there that want to chase a career
and everything I'm not saying don't
chase a career and don't make money just
know the consequences of that are you're
going to have a smaller pool of suitable
candidates that meet your requirements
and on top of that it's not going to
increase your sexual market value your
money does not equal come into that like
it does for a man so
chase her career but you should also be
working on trying to find a guy as well
and the thing is that women prioritize
chasing a career and they don't actually
prioritize like being a good girlfriend
or being a good wife or being a a good
partner for a man and they're going to
put their career over that and the thing
is is that you have the most negotiating
power and ability to lock down a high
status man that you want when you're
young and attractive not later on
they're they're not trying to be what
men want they're trying to be what
Society has told them to be yeah and so
you can keep saying social construct
over and over and over again but the
reality is guys you look at okay Cupid's
data and they behave a certain way by
all means feminists you're allowed to
insult those men I when I did the
segment they were like you know Tim pool
is basically saying that men are losers
who are immature and I'm like fine I
don't care I'm not saying it's wrong I'm
saying if that's what you believe you're
allowed to believe that you're allowed
to be upset that men don't want to date
you just recognize that's what the data
shows and I'm not saying it's a good
thing but it's literally the studies
come out from several different Outlets
saying guys want 22 year olds yeah they
don't care about career in fact salary
is bad
high paying women men don't like it
right for whatever reason and women when
this is what we find in the study when a
woman makes six figures she won't want
to stay in a relationship with a man
who's making the same amount or less
than her yep I'm not saying it's all
women and I'm not saying it's a good
thing that's just what the studies come
out they show I'll take it a step
further yeah career women the least
happy demographic of female I think it
was a study from 2011 yeah of human
being actually 42 year old woman
unmarried no children in a career yep
that is the least happy demographic of
human being and I've said this before on
the podcast you guys could say it's
controversial or not I say women don't
derive this derive the same pleasure and
uh fulfillment from careers and earning
money that men do men are built to work
hours and go through adversity and earn
and bring it home to a family women are
not and that's why just like you said
before the reason why so many women
divorce a man if they make more money
than them or whatever is because when
you're the breadwinner it inadvertently
puts you in a leadership position within
the relationship and I've said on the
podcast before women are incapable of
Leading Men within the confinements of a
relationship and as an matter of fact if
you put on that leadership role she's
going to lead you all right to the end
of the relationship because women are
not built to lead or provision long term
for men period thanks for checking out
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time